so uh hello everyone um
this talk is going to be about
boundaries and distinguishability for
simple sources
uh this is joint work with uh andrey
bogdanov from cust uh you all film us
i am
from technion akshay srinivasan from
pafr and myself dinesh from iit palette
so here is an overview of the talk
so we will first begin with a few
central notions that we will be talking
about throughout the talk we'll
introduce them and then talk about the
key question that we ask
then tell our results
and
motivate why these questions and the
results are interesting and and also
tell us briefly about certain
connections between our results and some
known conjectures studied elsewhere
then we will try to give some more
details on on one of the result and
conclude with some open products
okay so
let's get started so the first notion
that we were talking about is this
notion of indistinguishability
let us say x and y are two distributions
over n bit strings and
when do you say that
and k is some integer
when do you say that these two
distributions are k wise and
distinguishable uh you say that these
two distributions are k y is
distinguishable if every k coordinates
of these two distributions are identical
that is they are identically distributed
okay that is you call them uh k y's and
distribution
so let us look at
some examples
so let us say x is a uniform
distribution over even parity vectors
and y is a uniform distribution over o
parity vectors
okay and ah these two distributions are
n minus one y's and distribution
um so for instance if you look at
any n minus one coordinates um they are
all possible n minus one strings are ah
going to be going to appear with equal
probability and hence any n minus 1
coordinates are uniformly distributed
and same for apply same applies for the
y distribution
so these two distributions are n minus 1
y distribution
and let's look at uh one more example um
so let's say z is the following
distribution it's
given by a1 b1 a1 plus b1 a2 b2 a2 plus
b2 and so on where
ais and bis are like
unbiased random bits
and let's construct a
x and y outfit where x is
a z condition on the fact that a i sums
0 and y is z condition on ah a is
summing up to 1.
so so i won't be arguing this completely
here but um but uh these two
distributions are actually uh n minus
one risen distinguishable and uh some of
the dis in fact in later on uh we'll be
looking at uh some of the distribution
some of the distributions that we'll be
looking at will look like these kind of
distributions this z distribution
okay so see the x and y coming out of
the z okay so
let's
move on to a slightly more familiar
notion which is
independence
um so let's when do you say that a
distribution x
or n bit strings is this is k y is
independent so you say that it's k y is
independent if every k
coordinates looks uniform
okay so let's uh look at an example uh
so before that so how is this related to
the previous notion um so if so a
distribution x is ky independent if ah
if if x and you if x and y and the
uniform distribution are k y
distribution
ok so ah so here here are
three examples
so the first example is the following so
you look at a uniform distribution over
our even parity vectors
these are n minus 1 y independent
and
this this argument could somewhat be
generalized to uh say that um if the
if it's a uniform distribution over a
substitu is over a subspace where the
shortest linear relationship between the
coordinates is of length k then it is a
k minus 1 wise independent distribution
um this again requires a bit of an
argument but it is related to
codes and dual distance of ports
so that those are two examples and let
us look at the third example which is a
z distribution that we saw in the
previous slide
in fact you can show that it is it is
actually twice independent
but it is not three ways independent
okay so now given this lets sort of
go towards the
question that we have been that we want
to that we ask in this work so um before
that uh
we will be talking about uh
these kind of uh
circuits which are unbounded fan and or
not
boolean uh boolean circuits with
which are of constant
okay so let's look at this nice result
due to ah braverman so what does
briberman's result say
so suppose you have a polynomial sized h
zero circuit um
and you think of the following two
experiments where in the first
experiment you give it uh completely
uniform uh random bits and in the second
experiment you and and and observe its
output and the second experiment you
look at uh you gave it a polylog and
wise independent random randomness hold
on wise independent distribution and
observe its output and
what braverman's theorem shows is that
ac 0 circuits cannot tell apart between
these two distributions or in other
words uh polylogin voice independence um
four layers of prostitutes
and what is remarkable about this result
is that um
so this is the following so um so think
of the following kind of
distinguishes following kind of uh
following kind of objects which is
trying to look at uh tell apart these
two distributions so these these
distinguishes can only look at polylog
and many bits and
of course because of the fact that the
distribution uh is k y is independent is
poly log and y independent you cannot uh
these kind of distinguishes cannot
distinguish between poly log and y and
depend on nominal voice independent
distribution and uniform distribution
and what braverman's theorem sees is
that um
this goes all the way to
this could be generalized all the way to
a zero uh that is even if the h0 circuit
looks at the entire
end bits it still cannot distinguish
between the two distributions so one
could think of this as a fooling
escalation
and and what is the question that that
that we start off with is is the
following is whether ah braverman's
theorem this the same theorem holds if
you replace ah polylog and voice
independence by ah polylog and voice
indistinguishability
and in fact this is precisely the
question that uh program vishai uh viod
and williamson asked and
it turns out that the answer is no and
it
follows from
this result of nissan and security so
what did the sun and secretary show
design and security showed that the
approximate degree of r or function uh
is
written
or an n built in and by an lp duality
argument this shows that there exists
root and wise and distinguishable
distributions that
that even or can distinguish
so
um so this basically says that uh you
need at least root and voice and
distinguishability to have some sort of
a browerman style theorem
so so question that
that still comes is is it still true
that
maybe browerman's theorem is true
because the distributions that comes out
of it
might be too complex and that's why the
braverman's theorem need not be true but
what if we insist that the distributions
are somewhat simple
does browerman's theorem holds for
polylog and wise indistinguishable
simple sources
so
so what do we mean by
simple sources so simple sources are
these kind of sources these are sources
that are easy to sample given ah iid
uniform random list
okay so here are some examples that we
consider in our work so um so the so one
of the sources local sources that is
each bit of the distribution is a
function of a constant number of random
bits those are local sources and what's
a linear source each bit of the
distribution is a linear function as a
linear combination of the random bits
and what are quadratic sources
these are
distributions where each or each bit of
the distribution is a degree two
polynomial on the randomness and these
comes up in ah some certain
cryptographic applications which will be
talking about uh soon enough and now um
uh
having told you the what is the simple
source let's uh jump into
our results
so these are the uh kind of results that
we that we have so we have two kind of
uh results actually where we uh show
that a browerman style theorem is true
meaning there are there exist certain
simple sources uh which are which are k
wise distinguishable um which certain
kind of distinct for which which is
which certain kind of distinguishes uh
uh
distinguished fools and for certain
values of k so so what are our results
um so if the source is uh is of constant
degree or constant locality um so where
constant degree meaning uh each output
bit depends is a
could be expressed as a polynomial over
the randomness of constant degree um if
the sources of this ah nature and for
for k being constant uh we could show
that uh these kind of uh distributions
uh pair of distributions which are k
wise dismissable for this for a constant
k would fold r
and um
we could also show um for depth one
sources where each output bit of the
distribution could be expressed as a
could be computed by a depth one circuit
uh on the randomness uh so uh so for
such kind of sources um uh we could show
that and for the for the value k is
equal to uh for k being log log n uh we
could show that it uh folds the r
function and um for linear sources uh
for polylog and voice and
distinguishable distribution folds uh
local dnf where
these are dnfs of width
log n over log log n
and for quadratic sources fools
polynomial size
decision trees where the source is this
polylog invoicing is initial
and
for the last two sources
it suffices if one of the source is
simple we don't need both of them to be
simple and
just to make keep things simple we are
assuming this uh
taking this distinguishing advantage the
difference of the probabilities with
which you could tell these apart as as a
constant
so so these are one kind of results
where you you can show that we can show
a brower man style theorem and this is
another kind of result where you where
you where
you show that
such a result is not possible
ah so what do you mean by that that is
there exists a pair of simple ah k by s
and distributed pair of distributions
which in fact of degree log n which
which are root n wise and
distinguishable but yet
r can distribution
okay so now having said this let's move
on to
why are we interested in these kind of
questions um so let's start off with so
where exactly k and distribution arise
um so so recall that k was independence
is something that is common that comes
up in the context of d randomization
where you have some randomized algorithm
where if you know that the analysis sort
of requires does not require pure
randomness but if it's okay giving
dependent randomness then you could just
uh replace a pure randomness by a [ __ ]
independent uh distribution and you just
need k log and bits uh to generate these
kind of distributions and for some
constant k you can brute force and get a
polynomial time algorithm and d
randomize so that's the usual uh
use case for kyc independence and where
does k wise and distinguishability arise
k basic and distinguishability arise in
cryptography so let me give you a very
concrete instance where ah k wise and
distribution arise which is this is the
secret sharing setting so let me explain
the setting so so so we have some set of
parties and some people and you want to
share a secret which is of one bit and
then what is the requirement that you
have you you want to share the secret
with all the parties and you want some
some r parties to be able to reconstruct
this correct while um all the parties uh
if if anybody if any number of parties
smaller than lesser than r comes
together and and try to reconstruct the
secret uh they will all fail they will
not learn anything about the secret
and what are the k wise
indistinguishable distributions um so so
think of the distribution x which is the
distribution of the shares when the
secret is 0 and y to be the distribution
of the secrets when the
distribution of these shares
to each party when the secret is one and
we can and in fact these two
distributions are k wise
indistinguishable where k is this this
value
okay and uh like at a high level uh the
[ __ ] and discriminatability promise the
guarantee sort of erases because from
the fact that no k parties will be able
to learn anything about secret and the
secret here is the zero and one so
so that's a that's the instance where
this is one place where ah
k by s and distribution arise so there
are there are yet
and
there are more places and um
continuing um uh it is possible to come
up with uh giveaways secret sharing
schemes where you only have uh ky's
independence um and it's possible to ah
possible with with a linear
reconstruction you can ah and this is
due to uh
shamir secret sharing and suppose we
want to do ah reconstruction more
efficiently for instance you want to do
reconstruction in ac 0 then
it is we know that parity cannot be
computed in ac 0 and
in this situation uh ky's
indistinguishable distribution comes to
our rescue there are
schemes which which which from which
uses [ __ ] in distinguishable distribution
and
and you can use that to cons construct
secret sharing schemes which are in ac 0
which are an ac 0 reconstruction
and
so yet another place where ah k ways
is in this uh it's in the secure
multi-party computation and uh leakage
resilient and leakage resilience so what
is uh
secure multi-party computation so you
have uh some function and
and you have multiple parties and ah and
you want to compute and these parties
want to compute some function on on
their input and
how they go about doing it is they'll
they'll they'll share their
the information that they have and
and end up completing it and there will
be some kind of manipulations that will
do on their shares so that it doesn't
reveal any information about the shares
and
and the aim is to make sure that
no information is revealed and only the
function value is completed and one
common thing that happens in these kind
of protocols is uh there is a lot of
linear dependence that is created
because of this share mixing and this ah
sort of breaks ky's independence
property so this is sort of reminiscent
of the one of the distributions that be
the z distribution that we saw uh back
then but such kind of uh
manipulations does not ah uh break aways
in distinguishability this again
requires an argument and
and that and that's why k basic
distinguishability is valuable in these
kind of setting
and
right so so
so having
given this motivation
let's sort of ask
what is the point of proving a
braverman's theorem like what is it
why are we saying
what's the point of showing a pro
answering this in yes and answering this
and now
so um so if you answer this in yes
meaning uh there is a pair of there are
these simple ah k wise in distributed
distributions which certain circuits or
certain models which fool certain models
then that that gives you
leakage resilience for uh for secure
multi-party computation so
so what is this
what is this notion here so think of the
following setting where you have a you
have a circuit which is computing
something and
and you have you can tap into some k
wires of the circuit and
and you can read off these values while
the computation is going on um so in
some sense these wires leak some amount
of the information that is there in the
circuit and there are
there are there are
protocols multiparty communication
protocols where even if these k wires
leak values uh they will continue to
stay
if they continue to stay secure and
what
a browerman's flowerman theorem for for
instance for simple sources and aces of
a circuit would give is that
you get
you get that these kind of
protocols continue to stay uh
continue to stay leakage resilient
they don't leak much even if you allow
an ac 0 circuit to be computable on
these leaked values
okay so so one could think of ah as we
said one could think of browerman's
theorem as fooling escalation while one
could think of browerman's theorem for
for indistinguishable sources as
resilience excavation and
if the answer is no then it facilitates
construction of facilitates uh low
complexity secret sharing um so
so again
this was something that we saw briefly
before so um if you can do uh
if you can if if if there exist a pair
of uh
k wise and distinguishable distributions
which uh which can be four which which
ac 0 circuits can distinguish then you
can use that to
do
to have low complexity secret sharing
schemes so again the ac 0 circuit would
only be able to
tell apart these two with some advantage
but
you can boost this
but but in secret sharing you want to
recover it exactly but you can sort of
boost this
this difference by using approximate
majority which again is computable in ac
0 and
get close to perfect
reconstruction
and
we have the additional the simplicity of
the source gives this additional
advantage that the share is uh is simple
enough i mean the share generation is a
simple process
so
so so these are the uh so so either way
uh you you get uh something useful out
of it so so both questions like proving
it in yes or proving it you know
are ah are are interesting so um so
let's um
so one might wonder uh that okay so
maybe these
these sources are so simple that you can
you can possibly prove these results by
directly using the browerman's theorem
for for independent sources uh how do
you do that for instance
maybe one could actually
sample instead of giving if you are
instead of given uh purely independence
purely random sources say you might be
able to sample these simple sources
using uh ky's independent randomness so
so this sort of leads your question is
this is this possible to show that uh
you can you can is it is it true that
for simple sources you can just reduce
it to the uh government's theorem so
what we show is that is not basically
not true in fact in fact it turns out
that there are distributions where
there are some distributions which are
locally samplable from independent
distributions
which
for which you can indeed show that
show the bravo man style theorem
by reduction to bravaman and these sort
of distributions are inspired by
some secure protocols for completing
parity and we also show that there are
distributions which
which cannot be sampled by local
samplers uh from independent
distributions and these are uh uniform
random codewords from suitable suitably
picked ldpc ports
okay so having uh said uh this
let's uh
sort of dive into uh
yeah so let's sort of dive into how our
results are related to uh how do we go
about proving our statements and how is
it related to some of the known theorems
okay known theorems and conjectures
okay so so so we have some template
statements that we look at and
so let's say we have a class of sources
and a class of circuits so for
concreteness think of the source is
linear and circular says ac 0 and here
is one kind of statement that we
talked about so that the circuit
circuits of this particular class cannot
distinguish
k ys and distinguishable class resources
and this is this is precisely the kind
of statement that ah if you replace k
y's in this in distributionality by
independence you get traverman's theorem
this is one kind of statement that we
consider so another kind of statement is
a slight simplification of of this
in what sense uh is it a simplification
so ah so we consider
the kind of sources where sources which
are formed of this special kind let us
say you have a distribution x and ah
distribution x which is a simple ah
distribution simple source and um let's
think about the kind of think of it
think of construct two pair of
distributions uh construct construct a
pair of distributions from out of the
sex
where you conditioned on condition on
the first distribution you condition it
on ah the randomness r one being zero
and the second one where you condition
it on the randomness being one
and um
so let us consider such kind of pairs
which are k y distribution
and what this statement says is
that the circuits from the class cannot
distinguish between ah these kind of
sources ah k wise and dismissable
sources and
these distribution should remind you of
the of the
of the example secret sharing scheme
example where ah
sort of is a secret
and since this is a special case um so
this so the previous statement implies
ah this statement which is simpler case
this is a coset you can think of it as
percept in the in the cosets in the
linear case for this kind of
distributions and we'll consider we
consider yet another kind of statement
of the following kind where you have a
source
let's say you have a source x and you
have the property that no
k source bits no k bits of the source
reveal any information about r1
okay suppose this is the case if this is
true then the circuit cannot predicting
predict anything about r1 cannot say
anything about alpha
okay so this is yet another kind of
statement
and
turns out that this is equivalent to the
previous statement for the circuit class
that is considered here and the source x
that is considered here
okay so these two are equivalent and in
general we do not know if all these ah
statements are equivalent but if for the
case where the source is a fine
which is linear with a shift um
we could show that all of these
statements are equivalent up to some ah
constant factors of some factors in the
parameters loss and some parameters
ok so um so we have we have said some ah
statements so how so we now let us move
on to show some so connections between
these statements and some set of
statements that are ah studied elsewhere
in complexity theory so um so let's look
at this particular problem which is
inner product
computation with pre-processing so
what's the task here as your your
you want to compute the inner product
function ah
in a product of x and y uh using an ac
zero circuit uh where you are given uh
some arbitrary preprocessing of x alone
and some arbitrary preprocessing on y
alone
okay so so this is basically the uh in a
productive pre-processing problem and um
if you if you consider the
same problem where for
same question uh for quasipolynomial
sized zero circuits then uh one could
show that this is equivalent to ah the
question of whether the whether the
function whether the inner product
function belongs to the polynomial
hierarchy of uh computational complexity
which is a widely open problem
and um
so since and it's somewhat hard so since
these are harder question let's consider
a simpler variant
and one of the simpler variant that is
considered is where the preprocessing is
linear and in that case one could think
of the same question as computing of
computing inner product
where the where you have an ac 0 circuit
with the with the leaf with the leaf
variables the input variable is given
some parities
parity of the input and
and it has been known that so some some
restrict for some recipient versions
of this result like for instance for the
depth 2 case it is known that
that
detective case that is 0 circuit will
just be a dnf and it is known that inner
product cannot be computed by such kind
of
circuits and
and it is it is also conjectured so
cohen and sinker also showed this and
they also conjectured that
not only that they cannot compute in
fact they will make mistake on a large
fraction of the input in like they are
not correlated so
certain correlation bounds are um also
known but they are known for some uh
restitute setting
again also for depth two uh we did not
know anything for ah depth three or or
higher so so these are somewhat uh hard
questions and
we did not did not have much clue
how to
improve them
and what we show is that one of our
statement
say for instance the the particularly
for linear sources and ac0 circuits
is related to
this linear ipp question um so what do
we show uh in fact we show that um
for for for these kind of sources and
circuits and let us say k is like n to
the point one um if the following
statement uh that
no uh
k bits of this linear source containing
any information of r one implies that
the ac zero circuit cannot predict r1
then it implies that um
given a linear
given a linear preprocessing given any
linear preprocessing of of y
ah ac 0 circuit cannot correctly compute
in a product of x comma y for all x
and in fact this can uh be shown to be
equivalent to this problem of computing
inner product uh by ac zero circuits
with uh with uh the leaf parities
and um we sort of interpret this result
uh
as a as a barrier to
proving uh
browerman's theorem for or at least for
linear sources and ac0 circuit
and because these questions are hard and
there has been no progress for a long
time and this is one reason why our
results are mostly restricted to
our decision trees and dnfs
and
again let us look at the
results and
so
so we we classify uh
the results these results where you fool
the circuit as negative and uh uh the
kind of results where you exhibit k by
dismissable ah distributions which folds
as positive yeah because one would you
get secret sharing schemes which is one
of the motivations and that's uh and
these kind of distributions ex these
kind of simple resources gives you uh
secret sharing schemes
and now in the rest of the session
i will try to try to describe this this
last result in some detail and
conclude with some
with some open problems
okay so let's get started so what's a
task now so our task is to come up with
root n wise and distinguishable and
simple sources which
r can distinguish where the simple here
means uh of sources of degree uh order
log n so how do you go about doing this
we go about doing this
by the sequence of like coming up with
the sequence of distributions um
so we start off with this so the
transformation goes like this i'll
explain each of these steps so the so we
start off with this
distribution x 0 y 0 which is
which is a root n wise and
distinguishable
which r can distinguish and there are
several candidate distributions and ah
which are known uh due to spalek
bandalar and program shy violent
williamson and
what is important note here is that all
these distributions are not simple
according to the aspect the definition
that we consider
sources that we consider and
you can take any of these sources and
this
this step
we can we can start with any of the
sources and the overall summary is the
following so so in the step one you sort
of
resample the previous distribution as a
mixture of iid and following this we
will show how this mixture of ids could
be sampled using polynomial stage
decision trees then we will show how you
could uh
sample the previous this distribution
using ah log n degree polynomials
okay throughout we will preserve ah
indistinguishability okay and for for
simplicity let's uh let's think of
epsilon to be
some constant less than one um and uh so
let's try and describe each of these
steps uh so the first step uh our aim is
to sort of convert
the
the starting distribution which we don't
need to know the details of this
distribution let's
take the distribution and how we will
sample it as a mixture of iid so how do
you do it you sample this sample
according to this distribution x 0 and
and then you sample
some m bits uniformly at random and then
you output
the corresponding x from these indices
so you're basically duplicating some
bits and
and you choose um so you basically
choose this um
so you basically choose this um
m to be uh some theta of n and um uh for
uh for a suitable small uh for a
suitable constant t for a suitable
constant value of epsilon a for suitable
constant value of epsilon this will
incur some small loss in advantage for r
and you do the same for y and since you
are only duplicating coordinates ah
indistinguishability is affected it is
unaffected and
the resulting distribution that you get
continues to be root and wise and
description
okay this completes the first step and
at the second step what we do is we'll
show that you could
approximately sample
this previous distribution using poly
and size decision trees so so recall
that you just have pure random bits and
using a decision tree you can only
sample probabilities of these kind um
so so one of the difficulty is
you may not be able to while the
while the x 0 distribution in fact some
of the
probabilities with this you have to
sample are not of this kind
and
and the sampling processes
will fail and
and then if it fails we'll output zero
so um so so it's even though it fails
it's possible to still uh show that um
that the failure probability is low and
you can still preserve uh
indistinguishability uh this is some
detail which we won't get into and but
it's possible to handle this and the
second difficulty is is how large a
decision tree would you require where
the size of the decision tree is the
number of leaves and the size of the
distinct tree is actually governed by
the bit complexity of the probabilities
that are that we use in the mixture of
iid step and there are known
constructions for instance due to uh
banan talar where
the distribution has low complexity
we'll use such distribution
and so this sort of completes the second
step and the third step um we'll uh
we'll show how to sample these
distributions that can be sampled by
where each bit can be sampled by a
decision tree ah by a ah by a log in
degree ah
polynomial the logarithmic degree
polynomials and the idea is to sort of
approximate these decision trees uh
using randomized uh polynomials so so
what do we how do we do about doing it
um we'll express each output bit as a
sum of the sum of s many uh one leads of
the decision tree and we'll and each and
each of the leaf each of the leaf
corresponds to
some
path in the decision tree which is which
could be encoded as as follows some
literals conjunction of some literals
and we express it as this kind of a
polynomial where ah where our k j is our
fresh randomness and
and you express it as sum of this ah one
plus this quantity and then you express
it as this kind of a polynomial of some
suitability and um this should this is
actually this raspberry smolansky uh
polynomial corresponding to this uh this
form this this this conjunction and um
and the error probability probability
which these two disagree is uh can be
shown to be two power minus p and you
would choose d to be order log s to have
a small array and since s is uh poly in
poly n so it's a polynomial number of uh
it's only poly and then you can you can
get a
order login degree ah polynomial
so uh so in conclusion um so what have
we shown we have we have we saw some
browerman's style theorem for ah for [ __ ]
and distributing for some simple sources
and and uh and and some distinguishes
and um
as in the application is we have
applications for both positive and
negative results so the negative results
which basically uh shows fooling fooling
properly would imply leakage resilience
and and secure multi-party computation
and positive results would give low
complexity secret sharing schemes both
in the cryptographic setting and
we still don't have a
strong enough
browerman style results uh to show them
to show good enough to show some uh more
stronger applications in the
cryptography setting so this sort of uh
led us to look at uh
see why can't we actually show stronger
results and we ended up come showing up
uh showing some sort of barriers uh
improving government serum resources and
um and that's um
that's basically the talk all about and
now uh some open problems so so one of
the open problem is to sort of uh
show what is it that uh so for for the r
function we could show uh that there are
login degree sources which could uh
which which r can distinguish but what
is a what is the best degree is it login
or
we just know that it's between log n and
non-constant
and
and that's one question and the other
question is on this web of conjectures
so so we we have so we could show that
uh some one of the results uh
one of our so in fact we could show that
our conjectures imply some uh imply that
it would imply uh improvement in the
state of art of of some of the hard
questions and and circuit complexity and
communication complexity and um
and uh one question is are they
equivalent in in some way so uh is it
true that
these these questions are
would be equivalent and it seems
they could be equal that's uh that's a
feeling that we we get and um
if you recall we don't have any we have
only a barrier for ac 0 distributors and
linear sources we don't have any
barriers for ac 0 distinguishes and
local sources we could try and show
brower menstrual theorem for them and if
you could not show then
that would uh actually give you uh
meaning if you could come up with
explicit some sort of distribution some
k ways and distribution distributions
which could be which are which could be
sampled locally and uh zero circuits and
distinguish it would give you a secret
sharing scheme with a very low
complexity sharing and ac zero
constructions which and which you can
reconstruct in a zero which we do not
know how to show
using known techniques in crypto
and
and
thank you
that's it from